[Music]
hello YouTube just Louis in my friends
this is guns in here
welcome to the 46th episode of my dirty
chess tricks in this episode I'm going
to show you one of the Carlson's amazing
trick against Sicilian ostrov from the
white perspective the opening arises
after the following model E for C Phi
Knight to f3 d6 d4 C captures d4 Knight
captures D fall
Knight to f6 Knight to c3 and now the
characteristic nostrils move a6 with
stop any intrusion on the b5 and later
on black himself look out for the move
be fine here white has tried many
options but in the January 2017 Carlsen
come up with this amazing tricky line
which start with a3 very constructive
waiting wound
now if you check this position in online
database you will find out that the
highest played move in this position is
ePHI and which looks very natural
many modern nostril theory recommend the
move if I wear black get a superior
version of the sveshnikov as the knight
cannot go to the b phi square here it
has tried to move either Knight to b3
and Knight to f3
but Carlson has some another idea namely
night to afar well all the theory books
has dismissed this move because here if
black wish he can straight away get a
slight advantage position immediately
with the Moody Phi and after all this is
the break black wants to achieve
in almost all the Sicilians now before
we continue with the main line starting
with defy I should briefly note that
Black has tried other options but they
are not working very well for example if
black continued here with the Mooji 6
then I think this is already an
inaccuracy as Y can simply play Knight
to e3 and this night has been fast
routed to the D Phi square and combined
with Bishop to g5 white has obtained a
very good advantage many players who
don't know the theory has tried the move
Bishop captures f5 which looks more
natural in this position but after the
move he captures fi not only white
obtained the bishop pair but White has a
very easy plan of campaign what he wants
to do is he wants to play Bishop to g5
and then Knight to defy with a very
comfortable and easy position not to
mention if black continued with Bishop
to e7 then there is always a plan of g4
g5 rip apart the black King side now to
illustrate my point I like to show you
my game against a low-rated where my
opponent continues with the obvious move
defy grabbing every single space on the
center of the board but as I mentioned
earlier the plan of campaign is very
easy for the white yup you start with
Bishop to g5 pin down the knight
threatening the Moon Knight captures
defy so the obvious response is d4
counter attacking denied but after
Bishop captures f6 black has to capture
with the Queen as G captures f6 will
ruin the pawn structure and it's not
clear where the black King will go so
Queen f6 is forced afterwards we are
going to continue 8
knight to defy attacking to sports so
once again black response is almost full
he has to play Queen to d8 and the
forcing sequence continued from here
onwards
quint we have three threatening the moon
AB six black has to stop it
so the Knight to d7 looks the obvious
response but imagine the surprise yup we
are going to play the MU AB six anyways
if Knight to f6 then we can capture the
night and then capture on b7 so the
force response is G captures f6 but this
is a dynamic pawn sacrifice as white is
going to continue with Bishop to d3 and
here you can see already this light
squares are big problematic things for
the black camp for example in the game
black routinely turn out his moves such
as Bishop to g7 planning to castle on
the Kings side I continue with b4 so in
near future I'm looking for the move a 4
and B Phi and the same time also
stopping Knight to c4 idea by black and
amazingly enough my opponent castle at
this point and then he get this ultimate
shock Queen to a5 afterwards in few
moves black has to resign so accordingly
the best move for the black is defy and
surprisingly enough if you put this
position in any engine it will give
black a slight advantage okay no matter
why it should continue with Bishop to g5
the same old story
we are pressurizing the D Phi square so
black has to push forward with d4
afterwards Bishop captures f6 Queen
captures f6 Knight to d5 and Queen to d8
pretty much same sequence as we seen
earlier here white has to be careful as
black is already threatening the move
Bishop captures fr and then Queen
captures defy so accordingly in the
older games White has tried the various
options including
to g3 but in the January 2070 calcine
come up with this great novelty queen to
g4 so this mu has a great merit that it
not only support the snide
but right now what is also threatening
the Moon Knight captures g7 check
something black has to respond
immediately
if black continue here with rook to g8
then his King is going to stuck in the
center so that's not good in the game
actually Carlson's opponent avoid the
whole trick with Bishop captures fi
which is one way to play against this
line but after the simple move Queen
captures fi Knight to c6 and h4 Carlsen
demonstrate that this is a fun way to
play as a wide as White has a lot of
attacking chances where black has
literally struggled for the counter play
throughout the game I have attached the
whole game in the pigeon which later on
you can check out how concerned managed
to win that game anyways of a trick lies
on the obvious move what happens when
black continued with the moon g6 which
looks absolutely natural in this
position preserving the bishop pair and
asking the night hey what are you doing
on there Phi Square well here is the
answer
White has prepared this lethal reply
Queen to g3 black has to already know
what he is going to do next
otherwise the game will be finished very
quickly in the professional tournament
if you find out that your opponent is
playing the Noster of sicilian then this
trick is definitely worth to try it here
black has the only option that is Knight
to c6
but first let's look at what happened if
he tried other moves for example if you
continue with G captures fi then the
simplest is we can give this check and
at the end white will emerge with an
extra exchange and a winning position so
that's not a great choice for the black
well what happens if black defend the
pawn with Bishop to d6 now threatening G
captures fi well the answer is very
simple we are going to take this bishop
and after Queen takes White has this
winning blow Oh
so this Knight is attacking two pieces
and if black foolish enough to capture
the snide then after Queen captures ePHI
we again NAB the rook in the corner and
in fact the game okay then let's check
out what White is going to do after
Knight to c6 which in fact happened in
few games after Carlsen game where white
demonstrate the sting in the tail the
amazing resource Knight captures d4 BAM
warum ooh once again black has only
response that is e captors d4 if black
continue with other moves such as Bishop
to g7 then white can calmly be true his
knight back to f3 and he is a holy pond
up and instead of Bishop g7 if black
tried to capture with the night which is
in fact a blunder has after Queen
captures defy attacking three spots
Bishop to b6 and now instead of grabbing
the rook in the corner the line which
I'm going to propose goes as follows
Knight to f6 check King to e7
Knight to defy check King to e8 and now
you capture this night with healthy to
pawn advantage
so finally let's check out what happens
if black captured with the epon well I
think you already see that now the c7
square has been supported by the Queen
and white knight can simply slide into
juicy c7 square with Knight to c7 check
and after king to d7 and Knight captures
eight we have a unique scenario where
right now
Whitey's an exchange and a pond for
Bishop and on top black King has been
misplaced but black can also argue that
white knight is also strangled in the
corner and if black can manage to trap
that night then still the game can be
continued here if Queen to a5 then King
to diva is a very strong reply so
accordingly the best response goes as
follows beef I trying to play Bishop to
b7 and nab the knight as quickly as
possible and against this and almost all
of the responses White has this sneaky
move Queen to b3 looking at two
potential checks and surprisingly enough
black cannot defend both of them for
example if black continued with Bishop
to b7 then we can deliver this check and
after Bishop to d6 and the move if I
black position is completely busted he
cannot take with the night as the b7
Bishop will hang and if we continue with
Queen to e7 pinning down the e-pawn then
White has a very simple continuation
Queen captures Queen captures pawn
captures and after rook to e8 check King
to d2 and rook captures aid after the
whole transaction white emerge with an
extra exchange
so here it is very obvious that black
king has to go to the e7 square to come
out from all the checks and now black is
all set to capture that night so white
has to provide some forcing moves and he
does with Queen to defy attacking to
sports
so black response is almost forced he
has to play Bishop to d7 all said to
grab the knight in the corner but
surprisingly enough White has one
amazing resource which can literally
save the night before I move on I like
you to pause this video and find the
decisive move by a wide which can
actually tactically save night okay are
you ready
did you find the winning move by white
yup it's a four well this move
technically still denied as if black
foolishly take this Knight
then after a captures B Phi White has
created two pins and by force he will
get his exchange back so now black has
the only sequence which keep him alive
in the game and I'm very much doubtful
if you opponent see this position first
time he can hardly find out anyways we
need to see what happens even if he find
out over the board the sequence start
with Queen - if I check came to Devon
and now the star mu bishop - at six
threatening checkmate on d2 as well as
grabbing the knight on a looks so
threatening right but White has an
equally good Melinda's position namely
Queen to see if I checked King to f6 and
now before
Black has two choices amongst them if
Queen kept us before then this is the
easiest one as after Queen captures
before Knight captures before and the
moon night to be six white obtained a
healthy exchange and against the most
critical response Knight captures before
which looks very obvious in this
position white can create following
sequence which give him the winning
advantage
first of all Queen captures d4 check
King to e7 now Queen to see if I check
and it doesn't matter wherever the King
goes let's say in one game a black King
continues to hit King to d8 afterwards
White has a very simple reply namely
Queen to c3 pinning down the knight and
attacking the rook in the corner and
after rook to e8 which actually happened
in the game
white deliver this nasty blow a captures
B Phi and black Queen does not belong to
this world that's it guys I hope you
enjoy and learn this wonderful castle
trick against ePHI Najdorf remember at
this critical position play the move
Queen to g4
and after the obvious move g6 shock your
opponent with Queen to g3 and get some
great attacking fast victory well thank
you for watching this video feel free to
like subscribe and comment I'll meet you
in my next episode very soon bye and
take care